[Music]
hey you guys time once again for tomes
of terror this is my book review show
now just as on the previous ones i think
i say this at the beginning of everyone
but whatever just in case i don't you
know i don't know if
if we have new people like coming in or
whatever that are just like finding this
one
so i've been going through my kindle
unlimited subscription and trying to
find stuff that's uh available to read
for free on kindle unlimited that is
pretty highly rated and looked really
interesting to me and i've checked out a
whole bunch uh you know in anticipation
for the next couple of months
this one was one that came up very
highly rated and i have to say
graphic designers of which i am one
book cover design absolutely does matter
because
the cover of this book is
rad and it was one of the things that
actually attracted me to it because it
just pops right out uh the illustration
on the front of it so i did want to give
a shout out to the artist who did the
cover of this who's just known as tom
t-h-o-m
so i looked it up on purpose just
because i loved this cover so much so
this book is actually a novella
and it's called dirty heads
and it was written by aaron drys uh i
hadn't heard his name before he's
australian he's uh from new south wales
but he's written several other things as
well
and he is also an amateur filmmaker he
made a short film called placebo which i
think won some awards in australia
so this is his latest book i guess
because i mean it came out fairly
recently it came out like the end of
october 2021 and as i said it's a
novella so it's not super long i think
it's only about 130 540 pages somewhere
around there um and i honestly i mean
you could probably tear through this in
an afternoon and you probably will
because it's very fast paced and it's
very compelling uh the character the
main character at the heart of it is
just
he's such a great character that you
really really feel for him and you
really want to know what happens to the
poor kid
so there's that um i actually had to
read it in two sittings because i
started reading it and then i was like
oh my god it's getting late i really
have to like go do something else so i
had to come back and finish it up the
next day but i have to say even though
um when i first started reading this i
think it took like maybe
four or five pages before i really kind
of like caught the wave of it i guess
because and maybe i'll go into that like
why that was in a minute but
once it kind of got going i was i was on
board i was totally into it and i ended
up really really loving this a lot i
thought this was really really excellent
so what what we have here now apparently
what i've heard i wat i read the uh
e-book as i said because it's free on
kindle unlimited uh if you get the
paperback which actually i might do
because i did like this book a lot and
uh you know like i said i do like to
support independent writers uh but this
is an indie uh publisher
that uh he's working out through and it
might be his own imprint i'm not
entirely sure it's called black t-shirt
books i think the print version of this
actually has i looked it up on amazon
because you know how you can look inside
and it's really cool because the page
breaks um you know or the you know
section breaks and stuff like that look
like um you know like vcr tracking you
know because the book's called dirty
heads
and it looks really cool unfortunately
the ebook like the you know the graphics
didn't carry over
but the paperback does actually look
quite cool like inside the formatting
and everything like that
uh another thing unfortunately when i
was um researching this book is that
there's also a band called dirty heads
and when you search dirty heads unless
you search
dirty heads aaron dries
um you're gonna get pretty much all
stuff with a band because i had a hard
time i looked on youtube to see if
anybody else had reviewed this book and
i didn't realize i think adam cesar did
but it was kind of on a more
uh you know one where he was reviewing a
bunch of other things as well
um i did find a couple of snippets of
interviews with aaron drys
like at a horror convention and on a
podcast and stuff like that but not a
lot of stuff about this one maybe
because it's recent i'm not entirely
sure
but um you know so
i'm kind of excited to be the first one
to say because like i said i really
really liked this a lot and i really do
recommend it
so this is actually the very beginning
of it and like i said maybe this is why
it took me a little bit to get into it
but the very beginning of it is kind of
like is set in 2000 and it's set like
right or actually i think it's like new
year's eve of 1999 going into 2000
because there's stuff about like y2k and
everything
and we're following a uh 19 year old
named heath spooner
who is homeless
so there's kind of like a brief prologue
set in 2000 where heath is kind of
describing his life he's like eating out
of dumpsters and you know every now and
then like a nice person will give him
some money so he can sleep in a hotel
instead of on the street and everything
like that and he's hinting
that there's something some kind of
monster which he calls my monster which
is after him it doesn't appear that
other people can see it but it's sort of
left kind of vague
so after a few pages of that
we actually go back to
where the monster came from like the
origin story of this monster and what it
is so we actually go back to 1994 when
he was 13 years old and was living with
his family like his mom and his dad and
his younger sister d
and from there you kind of get so once
that happens like once you go back to
1994
i was totally on board because i could
totally relate to this kid even though i
was much older than 13 years old in
1994. i could you know the kid was
it was funny because he wasn't really
allowed to watch horror movies but he
was so fascinated by the covers like the
vhs covers and things like that on
horror movies that he would go to the
video store and just like look at them
and then he would draw pictures and he
would kind of like make up what he
thought the movies were about because
he'd never actually seen them and even
in his room at home he has like all
these horror movie posters of movies
he's never seen but he just like really
really likes them so it's so i really
got into the whole
vhs horror movie
uh video store vibe to it and also
there's a part where he makes like a
mixtape for a girl that he kind of
thinks he has a crush on which is like
the older sister of his best friend and
uh so i really liked that whole and he
had to like tape songs off the radio and
everything like that which i thought was
really funny i'm like oh i remember
doing that kind of stuff so that kind of
stuff was like very relatable to me even
though like i said i was much uh older
i was already in my early 20s by the
time 1994 rolled around but so there was
that so it was kind of like relatable in
that sense
so what we have is that heath slowly
starts to it's it kind of like is going
through
his life which seems
somewhat idyllic on the surface even
though he's kind of a small kid he kind
of gets bullied a little bit but he does
seem to have like a nice family he has
like a really good relationship with his
little younger sister he has a very good
relationship with his best friend and so
everything seems
fairly good
but
cracks slowly start to appear this is
essentially um you know the sort of
subtitle of it is a novella of cosmic
coming of age horror
so
it definitely is a coming-of-age story
it's also a coming out story so this is
sorry if you're into like uh queer
horror this is a good example of that
because
um you're kind of getting to it's not
this isn't really the only thing but
heath kind of coming to terms with the
fact that he might be gay in 1994 and
there's kind of like this big sort of
uh background thing of like you know the
aid scare was still very much uh
prevalent like in the media and so him
uh you know being 13 and maybe trying to
come to terms with the fact that he
might be gay and he might uh you know he
might die of aids and it's all this you
know like a kid would think and you know
trying to
be trying to like will himself to not be
you know what i mean
by you know
insisting that he has a crush on this
girl and all this other stuff so there's
all of that going on
but out of
those fears that he has um not just that
but there's some other things going on
with his family in particular his dad
seems to
generate
a monster like a literal monster which
kind of comes out of
they live in like a townhouse or like a
duplex and the one next to them is
abandoned
and the monster
seems to
kind of come from that abandoned place
and basically comes over into
his world
and
starts to
devour it or starts to kind of
terrorize his loved ones and things like
that this sort of it's not super
described but he almost describes it as
like kind of like a shadow with a lot of
teeth
things like that so
it it kind of reminded me a little bit
and i don't know it's not exactly but
thematically it kind of reminded me a
little bit of maybe like the babadook or
something like that where this monster
is generated out of like a negative
emotion
and it is sort of ambiguous as to
whether this monster is real or not
although
i don't even know if it's left ambiguous
i'm pretty sure the monster is real you
know what i mean because you know like
in the babadook the monster was kind of
like just a metaphorical monster more
than like a real monster
this one i get the sense uh that it's
actually a real monster because
even though
the things that it does you know yeah
you could attribute it to other things
sort of at least at first
but other people see it um it does have
an impact in the real world like in the
sense of killing people and you know
like i said other people seeing it and
stuff so
basically so i don't think this is a
case of just like oh it's a metaphorical
monster and the monster was just like in
his imagination or anything i just think
that uh heath's
struggles throughout his life his sort
of trying to come to terms with himself
as a person and like trying to figure
out who he is uh being a kid and trying
to deal with
some of the secrets that his family is
keeping in particular his dad generates
this
monster kind of like out of the ether
sort of thing
which actually just comes in and starts
like destroying his life and you know
ends up
many years later he ends up as this
homeless kid and that's pretty much all
i want to say about it because like i
said this book is fairly recent
and so i don't really want to spoil what
happens in it so this might be like a
fairly short review
but i will say i mean if you have a few
hours and you really like
sort of cosmic horror uh queer horror
any kind of like
coming of age type story then definitely
check this out because i ended up really
really loving this and i think that the
main thing that i liked about it i mean
yeah it has like a lot of gore
um a lot of really bad [ __ ] happens to
uh nice people and uh so there's that
but i really really liked the main
character of heath
the way that he's written you i mean he
seemed
very much like a real person to me he
was a very relatable
kid
and
just you felt so
bad for him just like the entire because
i mean the monster him making the
monster it wasn't any fault of his own
he wasn't a bad kid he was actually like
a pretty awesome like sweet kid
and it just kind of like happened like
that and then like all of the fallout
that came out of that was just like so
sad and so tragic that you just couldn't
help it but like feel for this kid you
know what i mean and i was like reading
some of the reviews on uh goodreads
there's not a [ __ ] time because like i
said this move this uh book hasn't been
out for that long
but a couple people said that they
wanted to like reach in through the book
and give the kid a hug and i was like
yeah that's exactly how you do feel he's
just like he's such a good character
like such a sympathetic character and
you see like all these terrible things
that are happening and he can't really
do anything to stop it he's just like a
little kid and it just
it's just like heartbreaking you know i
mean so it's just kind of like horror in
the grandest sense of the word because
just this kid that didn't deserve it but
for whatever reason his
fears his uh way of dealing with the
world has you know
unwittingly like unleashed a monster
into the world which you don't even
really know like how
that's gonna play out in the end like is
it going to
you know is it gonna swallow the world
is it gonna do all this other stuff but
it was just i mean this is just such a
great the character work and the and the
uh the writing is like really really
good it was like really evocative i
don't know i just really really dug this
uh quite a bit so if you like kind of
like
late 80s early 90s like retro kind of
stuff like i said old video stores
horror movies
mix tapes all that kind of stuff and you
like it with a little bit
of sort of cosmic horror like i said
like monster type of stuff coming of age
type stuff then you would probably
really really dig this if you have
kindle unlimited you can read it for
free although
as i said i kind of looked at the
paperback and i was like oh that
paperback looks kind of cool it's not
like
super fancy or anything it's not like
you know grady hendrix where he makes
the whole thing look like an ikea
catalog or anything like that but i just
really liked i mean i like book
formatting i'm a graphic designer and i
like book design so i even like little
touches
you know when uh when you design a book
so i really liked the kind of uh vhs
tracking type of situation that he had
going on like throughout the pages i
thought that was a really cool little
touch so even though i read it on kindle
unlimited i'm kind of thinking that
maybe eventually i will buy it in
paperback just because i liked it so
much and honestly too because i just i
love that
i just love that cover it's just so
awesome uh so and i kind of want to have
it so i think i think the paperback is
only like 10 bucks 11 bucks something
like that so i think i might end up um
just having so i can have like a
physical copy just because i like the
look of it so much so yeah um if you've
read it or if it sounds good to you then
check it out
as i said it's pretty short it's only
about 140 pages so it probably wouldn't
take you that long to read so
if you want to go read it uh check it
out and tell me what you thought about
it and that will do it for this tomes of
terror i will see you guys on the next
one
bye